catherine fulton from our board i think
this is a great one to to actually wrap
up with all right ass fundamentally if
if you are successful and this whole
thing is working how is the world gonna
be different ten years from now
I love the optimism that there'll be any
discernible difference in only ten years
that's awesome let's say a hundred years
yeah I mean we don't know I the
investment thesis for this raising money
for this is really interesting because I
can tell you what will happen but I
simply can't tell you when it's right
like right now we are on track to open
the exchange soon we'll be able to
solicit companies we have something
people love our theme in the near term
maybe next year you know we'll go public
on the exchange but like there's this
concept called the IPO window if you
will know like the idea that capital
markets are like open for IPOs for
certain amounts of time and then they
closed so like we're like one
catastrophic ly bad tweet away from the
markets crashing any day right so you
wake up in the morning you don't know
what's gonna be so like we have to be
prepared for the possibility that this
happens right away and the movement is
catalyzed and we get going or that we
live through a long winter before we can
make the change happen but so I don't
know when I just don't know when but
here's what I can't say here's my hope
it's not even really about
LTS DNR reforms of course I believe that
companies this next generation of
companies deserve to have a governance
model that really aligns incentives and
interests that employees deserve to work
in under humane working conditions where
they can believe the promises that their
own companies make to them let alone the
cup of promises that they have to
represent to customers I believe that
the investors are long-term investors
the pension funds the people who are
investing for retirement people who
represent the economic interests of
ordinary people they should be able to
participate in growth companies so like
I believe all that is good and can
happen but that's not really what's at
stake here to me so just if you let me
think bigger for a second my hope is
that this because if this works it will
inspire other people to reinvent the
rest of our civic fabric the
institutions that govern our lives in
democratic countries have been decaying
and are practically decrepid partially
from misuse but partially from people
actively hack
away at the foundation and then being
like hey we could use that for firewood
and look nothing fell over today so I
guess it was fine and I don't think this
is like too controversial anymore
I look around we are not we do not have
the institutions that are fit to purpose
for the 21st century but we also can't
go back our grandparents worked out a
lot of these solutions the hard way and
I just I pray that we don't have to go
through what they went through to build
the next set of these institutions
partly because we have the lessons that
we could learn from the sacrifices that
they made but also we can't just
copy-paste what they did because the
world has actually changed a lot in
three generations so we have to build
new civic infrastructure new you know
it's talking to Stuart about maintenance
new maintainable institutions that make
sense
for the 21st century it's not just
bridges and dams whose infrastructure
has decayed but every aspect of our
civil society and I'm talking about
schools and hospitals and newspapers and
political parties and government
agencies and you know defense
departments and everything has to be
reinvented and the lesson I think of the
last 10 years especially is that if we
allow technology to just disrupt things
and just trust that the market will sort
it out we will like things will be
disrupted and they will be replaced with
things that are new but we may not like
the consequences of that change because
if we don't have entrepreneurs with the
vision not just to build a commercially
viable product or a useful piece of
technology but they don't have the
vision to say there are Civic values at
stake and they need to be baked into the
fabric of what I'm building from the
beginning we don't make those choices
consciously we will get the results that
we deserve unconsciously so my hope is
that LTS C is successful in its own
right but more importantly that it will
inspire many people who are listening
and watching right now to say wait a
minute if it's just a forum
what's my version of just a form right
like why do we have to send kids to
school where everybody learns the same
thing at the same time every day
it's that necessary why do we have to
build hospital-wide why do we have to
build political parties this way why do
we have to do journal it's like
everything that matters that governs our
our liberal democracies take a fresh
look and say is there a humane
scientific you know customer-centric
21st century version of that available
and so I hope you know this works it
will inspire many copycats thank you all
very much
[Applause]
[Music]